Fox News breathlessly covered Donald
Trump flying from Florida to New York
City for his arrest almost like a soap
opera truly stunning where it is almost
Beyond parody making him out to be some
kind of martyr the coverage was led by
Harris Faulkner whose right-wing
leanings at least as far as the
character she plays on air remember Fox
News hosts and anchors really are
characters at the end of the day so she
may be as liberal as they come in her
private life I don't know but at least
the right when right-wing character that
Harris Faulkner plays has become
particularly weaponized over recent
months look at this we're going to show
you the entire trajectory of this here
is the coverage of trump leaving
Mar-A-Lago to head to the airport to get
on his private plane they call this news
there and now we've seen the second car
let's watch this live now the president
uh number 45 for the United by the way
the president the the president is Joe
Biden the states is on the move to Palm
Beach International Airport wow and as
we grab these photos I just want to
remind everybody the types of decisions
that have already been made ahead of him
arriving please one of them was uh the
Secret Service first of all is in charge
of anything having to do with the
president New York Police Department
here in the city will secure the streets
you'll have other presents inside the
courtroom tomorrow when he is arraigned
at 2 15 PM Eastern but for now the
Secret Service is in charge and so
they've already made the kind of
decision of whether or not you would see
him in handcuffs they had said no they
wanted to make sure that wherever he's
going to be had been swept this is a
former president we have never seen
anything like this what we have seen
1832 and then with Spirit Agnew uh under
Nixon we have seen former vice president
and then a sitting vice president with
Spiro Agnew face an indictment in
charges but what we have not seen
is a former commander-in-chief
indicted in a state now that he used to
live in doesn't live there and look at
the people that are lined up against the
freeway like everybody knows the route
and this is a very very short ride I
mean yeah it looks like mostly reporters
filming quite frankly but really making
it almost like a parade-like atmosphere
and indeed as they got further in on the
trip it feels as though this is like the
Macy's day Thanksgiving Day Macy's
Parade or something and Kaylee I think
it's what you're telling me I I look at
all these people on the roadside and yes
some of them are law enforcement but a
lot of these are citizens yes summer law
enforcement and summer reporters with
cameras but there are some citizens
there dozens potentially of people
friends who know this route and he's
going to slow down a bit for this yeah
apparently he sent a box of hats out to
some of those who are peacefully
gathered over the weekend yes they were
very very I like how now they always
mention P everybody's being
extraordinarily peaceful and then really
a more philosophical question my friends
what is the destiny of Donald Trump as
he boards his private plane what is
coming in his future his plane is
getting ready to take off now they are
on the move on the tarmac and this is
what we have been watching for and we
don't know what Destiny looks like on
the other side of this trip when he gets
here in New York city folks this is a
guy accused of crimes that's what this
is and they are turning him into this
martyr now I know many of you have
already said David that's why it's is
going to help him the fact that they are
turning him into the victim and into
this martyr and it is expected that
Donald Trump tonight at his press
conference at Mar-A-Lago is going to say
they didn't really indict me they
indicted all of you he is going to frame
this as a collective punishment of Maga
that they are punishing all of his
supporters for supporting him and for
the greatest political movement in
history or whatever
this is what has led to many of you to
uh writing to me saying this is going to
help him David this is going to help
them look at his fundraising numbers I
concede readily that this in this
indictment okay let's let's wait before
we say future indictments this
indictment helps Trump
in the Republican primary I agree with
that I don't think that if there is
another indictment in Georgia
and potentially a Federal indictment
that it will be good for Trump at all
because it really will hinder his
ability to run his campaign and secondly
I don't understand how this indictment
gets Trump a single new vote in a
general election this indictment and
potentially future indictments make
Trump seem even more chaotic than we've
already known him to be and the chaos
that surrounds him and so while this may
help Trump secure the Republican
nomination if it doesn't end up
interfering if the indictments keep
coming I think this is bad for Trump in
a general election that's my view as of
today if the facts change I will revise
that view as many of my viewers and
listeners of course know I have many
family members who work in the field of
mental health and I think one of the
most important things that we can do is
to both increase access and reduce
stigma when it comes to Mental Health
Services and that's why I am thrilled
that one of our sponsors today is better
help better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it is 100 online
with better help you can tap into a
network of over 25
000 licensed and experienced therapists
an important word therapists who can
help you with a wide range of issues you
answer a few questions about your needs
and your preferences and better help
will match you with a therapist that
meets your needs you can then talk to
your therapist however you feel
comfortable could be text could be chat
phone video call you can message your
therapist anytime you can schedule live
sessions when it's convenient and if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but it's on your
schedule
and it's at a more affordable price get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below